[Musica]
[Applauso]
io
non so
perché sono qui
voi vi aspettate un comico
io sono un illustratore
ero un ragazzo sereno
felice
prima che il decs mi avesse chiamato
venire
e adesso
quando quando penso che devo parlare a
cotanta platea io penso che ma
non lo so perché io sono abituato a
stare nel mio studio
da solo con la mia lucetta la mia
scrivania i miei pennarelli le mie
sicurezze
e so davvero quando mi hanno detto
parla dell'ironia
io so di non sapere nulla
di questo argomento perché parlerò
dell'ironia del mio mondo
e quindi un po come diceva perché questo
ho detto mi è
parso nella testa
subito appena ho sentito dire ironia era
un detto di socrate
grande filosofo maestro di filosofia ma
anche il maestro d'ironia
e bene buonasera a tutti mi chiamo
federico check in e sono un illustratore
e sono anche una bomboniera di nozze
e voi vi direte ma santo cielo una
bomboniera di nozze sì io faccio il
caricaturista per gli eventi vado negli
eventi e disegno tutti gli invitati come
regalo questo è uno delle cose che
faccio
e ora vi racconto un po quello che è
stata la mia storia
diciamo che
quando ero giovane
io non riuscivo a comunicare con le
parole ero davvero timido ma timidissimo
non riuscivo ad avere un approccio con
le persone soprattutto con le ragazze
è l'unica cosa che avevo
di mio era saper disegnare
e quindi il fatto di disegnare per me è
sempre stato uno strumento uno strumento
di comunicazione
mi piaceva a stupire le persone mi
piaceva anche renderle felici
e disegnare per me era diventata quasi e
lo è ancora oggi
non fraintendetemi un'ossessione
positiva so che non esiste la sessione
positiva però per me è un'ossessione
positiva
tanto che quando passavano le persone
davanti a me a volte
io lo guardavo e già vedevo nei loro
volti
un disegno se io dovessi guardarvi oggi
adesso ognuno di voi saprei in uno
schiocco di dita come sareste
disegnati le linee dell'inchiostro
disegnate nei vostri volti
quindi ho sempre pensato lo devo fare
e probabilmente lo farò per tutta la
vita questo cosa questo lavoro
mi ricordo che quando ero veramente
giovanissimo andava in discoteca con gli
amici
e alcuni amici di questi ci lavoravano
all'interno di questi discoteche e io ho
questo facevo entrano gratis
entravo nel guardaroba nel box del
guardaroba mi mettevo in un angolo ok
al buio
illuminato solo dalla luce che usciva
che entrava dalla finestrella
di questo guardaroba e lì con i miei
fogliettini e la mia matita
pennarello
disegnavo disegniamo bisognava le
persone che andavano avanti indietro che
portavano gli effetti personali e quando
consegnavo il disegno alle persone
inaspettatamente queste cambiavano
espressione magari erano un po trafelate
magari erano un po di fretta magari
erano stanche ma
ricevere in mano questo disegno
cambiava veramente l'espressione ai loro
e questo mi riempiva di gioia
una volta poteva anche funzionare la
caricatura si parla di 25 anni fa
oggi il mio tratto è completamente
cambiato io sono passato da caricatura a
un ritratto cartoon izzato io lo chiamo
più semplicemente in inglese cartoon
portrait
e cos'è
è praticamente un semplice ritratto dove
io realizzo le vostre fattezze del volto
in modo veloce in poi qualche secondo è
però in formato cartoon
quindi
leggero
veloce e
ironico
ma c'è una cosa che che vorrei dirvi c'è
una cosa che mi preme dirvi
che nel mio tipo di ironia
c'è dentro un ingrediente fondamentale
per me che l'empatia
sta all'interno della mia ironia io
quando guarda una persona nel disegnare
la
cerco di mettervi in comunicazione con
lei cerco di
immedesimarmi un po con lei
e quindi quando sento dire alle persone
ma le caricature tia centro nano i
difetti a me viene la pelle d'oca
sentire questo perché in realtà l'ironia
non parla di difetti pensi di carità di
caratteristiche più o meno esagerate
non lo so un naso importante una bocca
più piccola due occhi non proprio
simmetrici ecco con il ritratto cartoon
izzato io riesco in qualche modo da far
accettare queste caratteristiche alle
persone che prenderanno in mano il loro
disegno e lo ameranno
e questo per me è in paradiso
vi faccio un esempio allora io d'estate
lavoro
a lignano sabbiadoro
lignano sabbiadoro è una città ridente
città di mare di vacanze nel nord est
italia vicino alla slovenia vicino
all'austria
e io ci lavoro sulla strada da ormai una
decina d'anni immaginate con me io sto
disegnando in quello passa socrate
socrate sicuramente si fermerebbe amy
guarderebbe mentre sto trafficando con i
miei figli i miei pennarelli e
probabilmente si fermerebbe
e mi chiederebbe di fargli una
caricatura io socrate me lo immagino
anche un po magari che ne so quel
cappellino come me con una maglietta con
scritto make frico not war il fico lo
sapete è un piatto tipico del friuli
patate e formaggio
fantastico io lo vedo socrate con dei
gusti culinari friulani
e quindi dal mio punto di vista lui
farebbe di tutto per avere una
caricatura magari mi butterebbe lì una
frase filosofica cercherebbe proprio
distro carmela insomma no e allora io
ora
vorrei chiedervi una cosa di aiutarmi
appoggio questo
tenetemi il ritmo il tempo fate così
[Applauso]
immaginiamo socrate insieme
bravissimi
[Applauso]
ecco me lo immagino proprio con il
cappellino
un po vacanziero
con tutta questa barba
[Applauso]
bravissimi
siete veramente a ritmo vi state dando
veramente la carica
mentre socrate è molto felice
[Applauso]
et voilà
quindi io gliela consegnerei poi la
caricatura
il cartoon portrait e lui secondo me
la prenderebbe e se ne andrebbe
sorridendo ma poi tornerebbe indietro
stile
che ne so tenente colombo mi darebbe una
pacca sulla spalla e mi sorriderebbe e
sapete cosa mi farebbe mi darebbe il suo
bigliettino da visita un sito dottor
socrate filosofo di altri tempi
e mi farei un amico
in sostanza l'ironia o almeno la mia
ironia deve far star bene io la vedo
sempre nel lato positivo
deve rispettare deve essere leggera e
deve avere un tratto deciso ma allo
stesso tempo l'ironia
sgretola e distrugge anche l'odio
ed è per questo che oggi più che mai ne
abbiamo bisogno
grazie